in 1987 a computer animator named Craig
Reynolds grew tired of rendering hordes
of animals one by one so he set out to
find a way to automate the process he
came up with Boyd's simple software to
create surprisingly complex group
behaviors each virtual individual in
this case each paper plane is guided by
just a few straightforward rules with
the right set of guidelines the
individuals combine to form a unified
flock moving and reacting together
Reynolds flocks were remarkably
realistic making some scientists wonder
if real-world swarms were organized from
the bottom up biologist Ian's cousin
started looking for rules that might
explain how locusts congregate into
swarms using computer vision software to
map their positions and orientations he
discovered that locusts eat each other
from behind propelling their neighbors
forward as they try to escape just a
single rule the rule of
self-preservation ultimately leads to
the plagues of locusts we see in nature
now these rules are being discovered in
all sorts of biological systems at his
lab at Princeton cousin is applying
computer vision techniques to understand
the rules that govern schools of tiny
fish called golden shiners and it may
turn out that crowds of humans have more
in common with schools of fish than we
ever imagined
you